as history often teaches us sometimes
human beings are the biggest monsters of
all of course when you join the ranks of
the SCP Foundation that starts to seem
even less likely and why wouldn't it
after all just look at some of the
creatures they encounter and keep in
containment a giant unkillable lizard a
being with toothy protrusions growing
out of its body a whole host of immortal
Eldritch beings that could destroy
reality and one sadistic old man who
drags unsuspecting victims into his own
personal hellscape monsters are a dime a
dozen to the foundation Humanity could
never be anywhere near as evil or as
cruel as the real monsters even on their
worst day or at least you'd think
researcher Council had held much of the
same mentality that the SCP Foundation
had the job of Defending Humanity from
the real monsters of the world and it
was because of that belief that he had
never previously questioned the
containment procedures in place for
scp-1000 these beings were a species of
nocturnal and omnivorous Apes usually
with bodies covered in either gray brown
black red or white fur possessing the
same level of intelligence as the common
chimp the scp-1000s had been
colloquially described as a species
known as Bigfoot linking them to the
urban legend about an ape-like being of
dubious existence Kelton had hardly been
surprised that Bigfoot itself was an
anomalous SCP there were already a
number of others that the foundation had
encountered that seemed to have
influenced popular folklore from
different parts of the world in fact it
was that unique subcategory of anomaly
that Kelson was conducting Research into
when he came across the scp-1000 files
he was trying to determine in various
cases which came first the anomaly or
the legend did the existence of
scp-1000s inspire earlier human
civilizations to pass on stories of the
Sasquatch or at those Word of Mouth
Tales been somehow linked to the very
origins of scp-1000 themselves studying
the files Kelson knew there was a
memetic disease infecting hominids like
scp-1000 the infection meant that anyone
who observed one of the Bigfoot
creatures had at minimum a two percent
chance of suffering instantaneous brain
death it would make discovering the link
between the Sasquatch Legend and
scp-1000 difficult not being able to
directly look at the Apes but Kelson
hoped he wouldn't need to actually
observe the creatures only find evidence
that proved which predated witch
scp-1000 or the legend of Bigfoot the
population of scp-1000 was limited
although their highest concentrations
were known to be found in the Pacific
Northwest region of North America as
well as in the Himalayan Mountain range
in Asia being stationed at a foundation
facility in the U.S researcher Kelson
opted to mount an expedition to the
former location a few odd occurrences
had taken place leading up to his
departure his car tires had been slashed
and now needed repairing newspaper
clippings were also left on kelson's
desk that told of various hikers deaths
taking place in the Pacific Northwest a
more paranoid person might interpret
these as subtle indirect threats it
certainly seemed as if someone in the
SCP Foundation wasn't keen on celtsin
departing for his research trip
nevertheless he changed tact and called
in sick to work sneaking away to a small
airstrip and boarding a light cargo
plane that smuggled him towards the
forests of North America once he had
arrived Knight was already falling
Kelson was on his own traversing the
woods as the sun rapidly receded out of
view behind the tree line leaving the
forest in darkness save for the beam
from his flashlight the researcher was
hardly an outdoorsy type and far from an
expert at exploring the Wilderness but
he pushed on Into the Heart of the woods
to the areas where the most sightings of
scp-1000 and had been reported it wasn't
long before the Torchlight fell over
something imprinted in the Woodland
floor a large footprint left by
something by petal and rather similar to
an ape venturing further the sound of
Twigs breaking caused celtsin to whirl
around the noise had come from nearby
making it louder than the low background
Ambience of the forest at night he swung
his flashlight in the direction he
thought it had come from only seeing the
shadows of branches cast against the
tree trunks then another noise leaves
rustling as something passed by followed
by more snapping of Twigs than the
shaking of the leaves again this thing
whatever it might have been was
encircling him frantically Kelton tried
to spot it with his light when suddenly
the beam fell over something tall a
hulking figure moving between the trees
even from that split-second sighting it
was clearly an instance of scp-1000 the
momentary Glimpse had reminded the
Intrepid researcher of an important
detail he couldn't look at them a two
percent chance of instant brain death
seemed too low to worry about but
kelton's research had described the
effects of the memetic disease to be
cumulative the longer an scp-1008 was
observed the higher the chance of being
killed on the spot by the infection
snapping his eyes shut as tight as he
could Kelton was frozen to the spot at
the mercy of the sounds surrounding him
the scp-1000 was drawn closer enough for
the researcher to detect its footsteps
his pulse quickened along with his
breathing to match although he was
already aware that the Apes weren't
known for being aggressive hearing its
heavy breathing as it drew nearer was
enough to make him uncertain Kelton
wasn't sure if the Bigfoot would attack
him or pass him by but by far the last
thing he had expected was to hear it
start speaking
came a deep gravelly voice it was the
kind of sound an animal makes that can
almost be mistaken for Beach Kelton
wasn't fully convinced it had been a
word rather just his ears Playing Tricks
on him in a moment of heightened fear
human it repeated much clearer there was
no mistaking it a second time the
scp-1000 had spoken yeah
you can talk Kelton exclaimed in
disbelief the Sasquatch didn't answer
directly instead the researcher detected
the sound of receding footsteps there
was a pause as the scp-1008 turned back
to Kelton follow human it said open your
eyes and follow me what what about the
disease Kelton shouted keeping his
eyelid still screwed shut the ugly safe
the ape replied before it resumed
walking away cautiously opening his eyes
and lifting his flashlight Kelton could
see the hairy figure making its way
through the forest its back turned to
him he could see it the researcher could
look directly at it and yet nothing
seemed to be happening no adverse side
effects no instant brain death the odds
were low Kelton reminded himself as he
began to warily follow the path of the
ape following at a distance he made sure
to momentarily glance away trying not to
stare for too long at the scp-1000
creature in the hope that disrupt the
memetic effect of the infection before
long they had arrived at a cave deep in
the heart of the forest The Embers of a
small fire were still a glow near the
rocky entrance as they lumbered inside
the scp-1000 threw extra wood on the
fire poking it with a long stick until
the Flames began to reach higher the
flickering orange gave Kelton a better
look at the ape its large frame covered
almost head to toe in brown fur there
was also something about the creature
that seemed off not unsettling but
almost sad melancholic like it was
lonely the researcher had been so amazed
that he could observe the creature for
so long without dying that he barely
focused in on the more important
Discovery
scp-1000s were far more intelligent than
the foundation files had indicated
capable of not only speech but emotion
too do you have a name Kelton stammered
unsure where to start glycore it replied
that is my name yeah you'll have to
forgive me I'm a little taken aback by
all this the researcher hastily
explained yeah you're able to articulate
your species is it Advanced enough to
have names why should that be surprising
gricor asked oh well it's just the
foundation seems to think you and your
kind are I don't mean any offense but
mindless beasts the ape made a huffing
exhaling sound Kelson noticed after a
moment that they were chuckling a dry
almost sarcastic chuckle it was unlike
anything he had expected to learn about
scp-1000 that reminded him of why he'd
come here
um Greg core uh may I ask something he
cleared his throat nodding the scp-1000
instance poked at the fire again paying
little mind to the human in its company
where did you and your people come from
Kelton asked what's your history why
ricor replied abruptly uh you see humans
have these Legends stories about
something called Bigfoot or Sasquatch
Foundation the humans I work with they
call you one in the same I wanted to
know if that was true for a short moment
the creature paused then Gregor began to
give Kelton the truth the real truth and
as they spoke it was as if the
researcher could see the story unfolding
emphasized by the pain in the Apes teary
eyes we were like you long long ago it
began explaining we in humans we evolved
together side by side for a time there
was peace between us but we began to
grow faster stronger became smarter
while you were left behind you evolved
before early humans did Kelton probed
indeed cracker answered with a gentle
nod we began to surpass the humans you
were still young still hunting and
foraging for food while we were moving
far beyond thousands and thousands of
years we were able to develop up our
culture our technology all before the
humans had even come close to Fire and
the wheel but that doesn't make any
sense the researcher interjected yet
again if that was the case mankind would
have never had its chance to reach the
top of the food chain we would have died
out and that would have made you the
dominant species on the planet we were
the scp-1008 replied for a Time what
happened Gregor turned with a solemn
look on their face you it replied
plainly humans happened we covered the
world billions and billions of us you
were rare as few as we are now my people
made technology far beyond anything
humans have dreamed of either before or
since trains ships Vehicles created from
the trees and the Animals communication
using parts of insects and smaller
creatures cities filled with us where we
lived in harmony stretched out across
parts of the world humans dared not
tread organic technology Kelton gassed
fascinating we had weapons too and that
was our biggest mistake what kind of
weapons the researcher quizzed the ape
given how advanced you were compared to
humanity at that time I'm assuming your
Weaponry was far beyond our early Spears
in clubs the devastating kind griker
said staring ahead into the fire almost
if the dancing Flames conjured up images
of the kind of Destruction his ancestors
weapons could cause I think I understand
Kelton said there was some kind of
conflict yes a majority of your people
perish oh my condolences that that would
have removed you from the top of the
evolutionary chain and allowed the
earliest ancestors of humanity to usurp
your place there was the disease you and
your species carried a result of the war
a sort of lingering radioactive fallout
but on a genetic level we are not sick
crack or ground your people lied they
made that up and there was no war it was
a Slaughter Kelton felt quiet unsure of
what to say humans would stay away from
us back then we avoided them too you
slept during the night when we were
awake but you made a deal a deal with
something ancient and dangerous in the
forest a deal to even the score you
found our weapons and didn't hesitate no
that that's
the foundation researcher tried to
protest but the look of sadness on the
ape's face stopped his sentence before
he could finish we were almost entirely
wiped out in a single day humans switch
places with us we became less and they
became more they used our technology to
forget about us wipe their memories so
they wouldn't have to face up what they
had done but we will never forget and
the foundation they maintain that facade
Elton realized that's why they tell us
you're infected that if we look at you
we'll die they're ashamed
we all should be not just ashamed
greiker replied afraid they fear we want
revenge retribution for what was done to
our people and do you the ape took
another pause as if it was pondering or
just allowing itself a moment to feel
sad we have forgiven you that answer I'm
not sure we deserve that Kelton said
back as the pair Sat by the fire until
the sun came up now go and check out
scp-323 wendigo skull and scp-023 black
shock for more anomalous entities that
are pulled straight out of folklore
myths and ancient legends